WAIT ONE MOMENT PLEASE. MEMBERS
PLEASE COME TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FOR SENATE SESSION. FOUR NINE
AM SESSIONAL SENATORS PLEASED
TO THE FLOOR.
BARAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES. FOR
JUST BRADFORD CABALLERO CHIANG
DALLY DODD THE RAZA GALGIANI
GONZALEZ GROW HERTZBERG HILL
HUESO HURTADO JACKSON JONES
LEYVA MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MITCHELL
MORNING MORLOCK MORALE. NIELSEN.
PAN PORTANTINO RALPH RUBIO
SKINNER AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER WILK. COLLEAGUES A
QUORUM IS PRESENT MEMBERS TODAY
WE HAVE SENATORS BELL GLAZER
AND STERN PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY WELCOME SENATORS. DO
WE HAVE THEM ON THE SCREEN. WE
DO NOTCHARGE THE SENATORS WILL
PARTICIPATE IN DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE BUT WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING IN THE QUORUM
CALL OR THE VOTE ON MEASURES.
WITH THAT WITH OUR MEMBERS AND
GUESTS BE ON THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THISMORNING
BY SENATOR MONNING AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND WE
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG BY
SENATOR TO RUSSIA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS GOD OF
HEALING AND MERCY YOUR COMFORT
AND STRENGTH IN TIMES OF SUDDEN
DISASTER CRISIS OR CHAOS
SURROUND US NOW WITH YOUR
GRAYSON ASSISTANCE THROUGH THE
DEVASTATING FIRES ENGULFING SO
MANY PARTS OF CALIFORNIA. WE
PRAY THAT YOUR HEALING PRESENCE
WILL BE FELT BY THOSE WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR HOMES AND
POSSESSIONS. GIVE COURAGE AND
STRENGTH TO THE FIREFIGHTERS
AND RESCUERS AS THEY WORK TO
SAVE LIVES AND HELP THE FIRE'S
DESTRUCTION. WE PRAY FOR WISDOM
IN SAFETY FOR THOSE WHO WILL
RESPOND TO THE MANY CHALLENGES
LEFT IN THE WAKE OF THESE FIRES.
HELP ALL OF US RESPOND WITH
GENEROSITY IN PRAYER AND
ASSISTANCE TO THE BEST OF OUR
ABILITIES. HE PER HERTZ FOCUSED
ON THE NEEDS OF THOSE AFFECTED
EVEN AFTER THIS CRISIS IS OVER.
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME I'M IN.
AND. ZERO IT IS. ALL. THANK YOU
SENATOR MORNING AND I KNOW ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF US HERE ARE
CONCERNS AND PRAYERS FOR ALL
THOSE RIGHT NOW PARTICULARLY IN
THE NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE
WHO ARE SUFFERING THROUGH THESE
HORRIFIC WILDFIRES. THE WITHOUT
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED UNDER
WITHOUT OBJECTION MEASURES
REPORTED FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
THE RECOMMENDATION DO PASS WILL
BE GIVEN THEIR SECOND READING
UPON BEING REPORTED IN ORDER TO
THIRD READING. WITHOUT
OBJECTION MEASURES REPORTED
TODAY AND TOMORROW WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION DO PASSED AS
AMENDED WILL BE GIVEN THEIR
SECOND READING AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED AND RETURNED TO SECOND
READING UPON BEING REPORTED.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES WILL
START WITH OF SENATOR MELINDA
BUSH AND THEN GO TO SENATOR
DORADO SENATOR MELINDA IS FOR
WHAT PURPOSE ME AT THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT I'M
MAKING A MOTION TO WITHDRAW
ESSERE NINETY THREE FROM THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE BE
BROUGHT TO THE SENATE FLOOR SO
THE SENATE CANNELLA FULLER
RIGOROUS DEBATE ABOUT THE
MERITS OF THE GOVERNOR STATE OF
EMERGENCY THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER MELINDA'S SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR A PURPOSE.
MAJORITY LEADER ASTRONOVA RIGHT
THERE IS A MOTION BEFORE US
SENATOR MELINDA THIS IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE SENATOR
HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR A
NOTEBOOK SENATOR. JONES ARE YOU
WHAT. I CAN'T QUITE SEE VICTOR
I GOT YOUR YES SIR FOR WHAT
PURPOSE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THE WITHDRAWAL THIS YEAR NINETY
THREE TO THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
DEBATE ON IT I BELIEVE THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS ALL FORTY OF US
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE ASKING US
TO HAVE THIS VIGOROUS DEBATE.
I'D SAY LET'S A LET'S DEBATE IT
LET'S PASS IT OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY AND- SEE WHAT THEY DO
WITH IT AND A STAR OF VIGOROUS
CONVERSATION WITH THE GOVERNOR
ABOUT THE EMERGENCY SERVICES
ACT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SIR
AGAIN- SENATORS MELENDEZ AND
JONES ARE ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO
BATES. I FOR JUST. I BRADFORD
NO CUT BY OTHER. NO CHIANG.
DALLY I DON. TORONTO NO
GALGIANI. GONZALEZ NO GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG NO HELLO. NO WAY SO.
NO FURTADO NO JACKSON NO JONES.
I LEYVA. NO MCGUIRE NOPE
MELINDA'S I MITCHELL. NO MINING.
NO MORE LOCK RICHARD AYE MORALE.
NIELSEN I PAN. NO PORTANTINO.
ROTH. PORTANTINO NO ROTH NO
RUBIO NO SKINNER. NUMBER NO
QUAKE OWSKI NO WIENER NO WELL I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENTEE
MEMBERS. ALLEN CHIANG. DODD
GALGIANI. MORALE SKINNER. I
NINE KNOWS TWENTY TWO THE
MOTION FAILS MOVING ON ANY
FURTHER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES SENATOR DOORASHO. YES
MADAM CHAIR I RISE TO PULL ITEM
ONE SIXTY FIVE AB TWO ONE OH
FOUR FROM CONSENT AT THE
AUTHOR'S REQUEST THAT WILL BE
NOTED THANK YOU SENATOR JONES
FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO LIKE TO
PULL AN ITEM FROM CONSENT ITEM
ONE SEVENTY AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY NINE AT THE AUTHOR'S
REQUEST. THANK YOU THAT WILL BE
THE ORDER. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE WE WILL
MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE SECOND READING FILE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1-286-214-0920.
THREE NINETEEN THIRTY TO FIFTY
FOUR FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE
SEVENTEEN TEN THE SECOND
MEETING FILE WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MOVING ON TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS SENATOR WILK WE
ARE STARTING AT FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE
SENATOR WILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
ONE IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
OSCAR GONZALEZ JUNIOR. TO THE
HORSE RACING BOARD MR GONZALEZ
IS VICE PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT
AND COMMUNITY RELATIONS THAT
ARE A FINANCIAL CORP HE WAS A
CONSULTANT FOR THE C. ISSUE LOS
ANGEL STREAMERS RESOURCE CENTER
AND ALSO SERVED IN SEVERAL
POSITIONS AT THE US DEPARTMENT
OF AGRICULTURE. HE WAS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON THE EIGHTH
OF AUGUST I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YU
SENATOR WILL CONSIDER ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
APPOINTMENT ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
I ATKINS AYE BATES I FOR JUST I
BRADFORD I HAVE A- I CHIANG.
DALLY I DODD. ROSIN HI CAL
JOHNNY FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL. I HUESO
FIVE PATADA FIVE JACKSON I
JONES FIVE LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE.
I MELENDEZ AYE MITCHELL I
MONNING AYE MORLOCK. MORALE
NIELSEN.I PAN I PORTANTINO.I
ROTH FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER.
NUMBER FIVE WHAT COUNTY FIVE
WIENER. I WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
CHIANG. DODD MORLOCK. I MORRELL.
SKINNER. ONE MOMENT COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR WILL MOVE THE CALL
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO SENATOR WILL THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY TWO IS A
CONFIRMATION OF WINDY MITCHELL
TO THE HORSE RACING BOARD MISS
MITCHELL AS A POLITICAL
CONSULTANT AND FORMER APPOINTEE
TO THE COASTAL COMMISSION AMONG
THEIR PREVIOUS PROFESSIONAL
ROLES SHE WAS VICE PRESIDENT OF
PUBLIC POLICY AT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WITH WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS. AND ALSO
SERVED AS CHIEF OF STAFF TO A
MEMBER HERE IN THE SENATE SHE
WAS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
AUGUST FIFTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
APPOINTMENT. SEEING AND HEARING
NON MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. I BORDERS
FIVE BRADFORD. I CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG. DALLY FIVE DODD.
DURAZO'S I GALGIANI FIVE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HERTZBERG.
I HILL FIVE HUESO I FURTADO
FIVE JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ. I
MITCHELL. FIVE MONNING I MORE
LOOK. I MORRELL. NIELSEN AYE
PAN HI PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. AMBERG HI I
Y. CASKEY. I WIENER AYE WILK I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN I CHIANG. DODD JONES.
MORRELL SKINNER. WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO MOVE THE CALL OR WE'RE
GOING TO CLOSE ALONE. OKAY
HIGHS THIRTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
THAT APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT
APPOINTMENT SENATOR WILL FILE
ITEM THIRTY THREE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY THREE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR GREGORY
GREGORY FERRARO TO THE HORSE
RACING BOARD DOCTOR FOR OUR WAS
A LICENSED VETERINARIAN IN
SERVICE DIRECTOR OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA DAVIS
SCHOOL OF VETERINARY MEDICINE
MEDICINE CENTER FOR EQUINE
HEALTH UNTIL TWENTY FOURTEEN HE
WAS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
THE FIFTH OF AUGUST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR WILL
CONCERNING DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS APPOINTMENT ANY DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION. SEEING AND
HEARING NON. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. I FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO I CHIANG. DALLY I
DODD. DORADO I GALGIANI I
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG I
HILL FIVE HUESO. I FURTADO FIVE
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ AYE MITCHELL.
FIVE MONNING I WARLOCK AYE
MOREAU NIELSEN I PAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. AMBERG I Y. CASKEY I
WIENER. I WILK I. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CHIANG DODD.
JONES MORALE SKINNER HIGHS
THIRTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THAT
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR
SENATOR WILK THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR IS A CONFIRMATION
CONFIRMATION JENNIFER TROYA YES
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IN SCOTT LIEU AS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BANK BOTH OF THESE
APPOINTMENTS WERE CONFIRMED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON THE
FIFTH OF AUGUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS
THERE ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES I FOR JUST I BRADFORD
I HAVE A BETTER. I CHIANG DALLY
FIVE DODD. THE RAZA I GALGIANI
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG I HILL FIVE HUESO. I
HER TADO I JACKSON HI I JONES I
LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE. FIVE
MELINDA'S I MITCHELL. FIVE
MONNING AYE MORLOCK AYE ZERO.
NIELSEN I PAN FIVE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER.
NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER AYE WILK HI. HIGHS
THIRTY THREE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED WILL
NOW GO TO FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE
SENATOR WILK. RESIDENT FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FIVE THE
CONFIRMATION OF THE FOLLOWING
THREE APPOINTMENTS JUDITH BY
MANY TO THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
HEALTH AN APPEALS BOARD
CARRYING YAMAMOTO TO THE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT BOARD HE
CATHERINE DEL BAR TO THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
THESE APPOINTMENTS WERE
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON AUGUST FIFTH ON THE
UNANIMOUS VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. ONE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE SIDE OF.
SEEING AND HEARING ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. AYE GORGEOUS. AYE
BRADFORD. I HAVE A I CHIANG.
DALLY FIVE DODD. THEY'RE
AWESOME I GALGIANI I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. FIVE HERTZBERG I HILL
AYE HUESO. I FURTADO I JACKSON
HI I JONES. FIVE LEYVA. FIVE
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S AYE
MITCHELL I MONNING FIVE MORLOCK
FIVE MOREAU. NIELSEN AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH I
THREE. I SKINNER. NUMBER FIVE
LAKE COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK.
I MY AGE THIRTY THREE KNOWS OF%
THOSE APPOINTMENTS ARE
CONFIRMED LET'S GO BACK AND
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE BATUM CHECKERED
PICTURES FROM MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. I CHIANG. DODD MOREAU
SKINNER. SIZE THIRTY THREE NO
ZERO THAT APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
DAILY FILE ITEMS UNDER
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT SENATOR
PORTANTINO. UNDER COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
MEET AT TEN FIFTEEN IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE. APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AT TEN FIFTEEN IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE ARE THERE
ANY OTHER. MAYBE AN OUNCE
MONTHS SEEING NONE BETTER
PROTECT. THE DESK IS CLEAR. AN
IMPRESSIVE THANK YOU SO MUCH I
COLLEAGUES- BE SAFE WE WILL AS
YOU HEAD HOME- AND I WILL SEE
YOU ALL BACK HERE ON MONDAY
AUGUST TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY AT TWO PM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
ALL LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS IS
RECEIVED AT THE DESK AND WE
RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT TWO PM.